in age I get girls sending me texts and
I'm like I am NOT going to respond to
this screenshot but you've always been
the merry guy you never were like Marian
I mean you were married at public times
right at one point I was married for
five years of Carmen with Carmen yeah
well you weren't multi-bear mayor before
that really those right shotgun Vegas ah
worst crazy twenty kids in our swing
right let's do something really
expensive and stupid I went to your
bachelor party you know though yeah yeah
good one that was do i what is it a
combined
it was a combined one yeah yeah I'll
never do that yeah so you were on the TV
show then what ciao till death do us
part
I don't think I don't think I was I
don't remember being on the show I
remember going down a dark hallway right
there was like a african-american man in
the suit and then it was in Vegas my
party was a man in a suit yeah yeah well
yeah black man does it have to be whoa
what is a racist by telling the truth or
is it racist by pointing out the
difference because the the Debord
operator on my show yeah Aaron I walk in
I'm like hey Todd what's happening
what's up Jessica what's up Dan do it
Oh crazy that you say that because I've
been thinking about that as of Lane oh
yeah yeah we do these little things
right that is like a little it is weird
why do we do this is this blackness
pertinent to the story no if it's not
right it's not worth men because it
would because what he was claiming yeah
if I may yes he was walking down and
there was a black man at the end of the
hallway he was trying to set up a scary
scenario oh yeah you're right that's
exactly what I did do it again I'll do
it the way I wanna [ __ ] do it Gilbert
don't ever tell me what time all right
whatever I'm in Vegas right I go down a
light hallway and well lit hallway at
the Hard Rock Hotel it was very well it
wasn't like some off the strip like and
there was a humanoid so we don't know
there was a humanoid yeah you know and I
forgot what he was wearing but he was
definitely not an Android but a humanoid
pink right and he goes welcome to yeah
he goes welcome to common like that
that's power okay right and I walked in
and there was just humanoids in a broom
and they were just doing things yeah but
here's the problem is I'm like with
Karma no we're gonna throw it together
it's gonna be really wild then like
Carmen these two girls want to take us
to another room I already said this
[ __ ] oh you're only live once I'm not
really feeling them did you notice there
was a bowling alley in that building no
because I noticed you know why cuz
that's all I could do
bowling yeah I didn't I did walk into a
room there was two girls naked yep on a
I think it was like a table of some sort
and they were dead dildos inside them
yeah okay
what do you mean it was like yeah yeah
it was that kind of like girlfriends
yeah but it wasn't the two ended where
they're both in one I think so special
connection
yeah they were human and they were doing
that and then um I remember I brought a
girl so this is what happened a girl -
yeah I just leave all that no but listen
Canady like if I was stupid
Dave if I went there single I would have
not got any [ __ ] I promise you that
glove but it wasn't a strip club it was
a private room at the Hard Rock Hotel
he's right though he's right that is a
nob averages yeah is the law there was
so many cool people there I was like
there's no way right but I did a NACA
conference a week before in Portland
what's NACA it's like a college thing
where you showcase you do stand-up and
you get dates okay it's like a show and
I met this college girl and I flew her
to Vegas and I was I wasn't fee was
until he at all but then when I once I
you know me what I put it know I go to
let's go to Dave Navarro right he named
dropped you - part of that good for you
yeah let me ask you a question you
jealous very am i jealous yeah of course
not two weeks ago question when you do
that when you do the fly someone out
that you kind of know as if I'm sure was
an internet thing right no I met her at
live metal I actually knew her I kind of
knew her yeah but do you fly them out
and put them in your room or do you fly
them out and get a guest room but I've
been friend-zoned in that situation but
I'd see that's the thing I need my own
room
well you but you've been you've flown
somebody out and not gotten laid no no I
need I need my say I don't mind the
rooms joining oh but you know like some
girls and I hate I hate to dispel the
myth everybody but some girls go number
two not all of I'm sure you don't want a
little space yeah and so I provide that
space ah you don't find it we like to
say see your way they got to go down to
the lobby
you have a point because essentially
you're strangers right you all know each
other why the hell would you share a
toilet with somebody you're just talking
and some of those rooms where you can
hear like every little crinkle or paper
from the next room that's not gonna
happen also you don't know you seem very
like you know kept well kept together
and I get a little on top of your game
but some of these girls they come over
and it's like within 15 minutes the
bathroom looks like a tornado makeup and
hair yeah eyelashes and different color
bases on the sink and oh my what is that
all about why can you get that together
I am well it's quite the opposite
between him and I he can't get his [ __ ]
together this whole house was an
explosion when I first met him yeah in
fact I've really really consolidated it
down to like a few things because this
guy is a hoarder I'm a hoarder
are you much I'm very much the opposite
right I own like three things yeah it's
like 70,000 things I buy shoes like
three shows at shoes a week but when it
comes to getting ready I get you know
girls we like to really yeah what did
you start a half hour earlier and then
just put the stuff away as you go like I
I use my toothpaste yeah all right but
you don't seem horny I mean this place
because you like because I her yeah Dave
she changed my [ __ ] life this woman
right if without her I would I wouldn't
want to live in an apartment just full
of shoes when I came here you can even
get to what kind of shoes any shoes all
about everything everything everything
so you wait in line and use it I don't
do it I don't wait in line I don't care
about walk like if it's and that's me
I'm sorry it's okay guys no I I just I
like to just a but what's up we have a
sponsor yeah
[Music]